happy new year it's 2018 and I am here
to tell you that even though the year
has started you can still get your 2018
David Pakman show calendars if it's
already January and you don't yet have a
calendar for the year what are you
waiting for get this one this is a great
calendar made up of original artwork
from three david pakman show viewers Dan
Burke Corey top kiss and Anthony Petra
mala who now has been working with us on
the calendar for four or five years at
this point I believe a long time
original comic strips really really
funny story lines you can get the
calendar for free if you want with a new
yearly David Pakman show membership at
david pakman.com slash calendar 18 you
can get just the calendar autographed or
not autographed if you want at david
pakman.com slash calendar 18 this is
what we call the your huh the Andy
Warhol I can't believe I just blanked on
it the Andy Warhol David Pakman show
thing and I think what we have here is
in the top left I don't know how to
describe that one you've got super Sayan
Pakman super Saiya
cyanide everyone had like kool Kat David
Pakman and for the top left top left is
okay cool cat David Pakman you've got
super Sayan Pakman you've got crazy hair
Pakman you've got me being interviewed
by Jesse Lee Peterson Pakman my
direction of frustration two of those I
think that the one on the right column
where I'm wearing glasses I thought that
it was Heisenberg Pakman but no I
actually am don't know I have an idea
for a name for that one I just kind of
keep it to myself though well whatever
it is I'm sure it's incredibly offensive
but I think that that is the heisenberg
filter it might just not really be like
a Heisenberg thing you've got pac-man
pac-man where there's a cartoon face of
me eating pellets sort of similar to the
pac-man video game you've got me at the
shaking crab in Newton Massachusetts
where I'm dining on as photoshopped
corporate media which is a good one
you've got Captain America Pakman on the
bottom row this is a cool image I like
this one and this was a this was a
hybrid quarry top gets did the original
version of this and
Anthony Pett Ramallah expanded it and
added funny images for the show needless
to say the one place to get the calendar
is david pakman.com slash calendar 18
whether you want just the calendar or
the calendar and a membership which will
make the calendar free we will take
orders for a few more days we will ship
these out as the orders come in thanks
to everybody who's already bought the
calendar 2018 it's gonna be huge folks
it's gonna be absolutely huge for us and
maybe you know do you think that when we
end calendar sales Pat we should maybe
light a small fire and burn the note of
example calendar that I have here
against us destroying things so we found
out you know it's paper so I don't know
that it's that big of a deal to burn it
although I'm sure we'll get someone
writing in saying that you're generating
you're releasing carbon into the
atmosphere anytime you burn anything
you're releasing carbon into the
atmosphere our children in third-world
countries who don't know what day it is
David oh so I should send them the
calendar yes yeah I don't know we'll see
what we do I usually end up keeping one
calendar here and I have like a stack of
all of them just as a little memento
anyway welcome to 2018 Happy New Year
hope everybody had a good end of 2017
and will be back with brand new
programming tomorrow